sure the b580 launched to kind of a lot
of fanfare a couple of gotas that we
talked about but mostly it's a really
good card better value than anything
else in the market when it launched
terms of frames per
dollar mostly but now today is the b570
launch and we have the Intel Arc b570
Challenger from ASRock and it's
overclockable and it has some really
interesting features 10 gabes of vram
it's a little slower but it also costs a
little less let's take a look
580 570 a lot of the time the better
value is in the less expensive version
of the product but this has 10 GB of
vram and is clocked a bit slower but
azrock is maybe making up for some of
the difference in terms of
overclockability which we'll talk about
but this is a small two slot truly a
two- slot card it would actually work in
a two- slot configuration still got a
little bit breathability the fans
actually sit a little bit lower than two
slots it's got a pretty good size cooler
is a little taller than average but this
would be a good choice for a small form
factor build this also only uses eight
PCI Express Gen 4 Lanes the layout here
also has an LED onof switch at the back
hidden through here and it has flow
through Co cooling so the the PCB on
this is actually quite tiny and the card
runs cool until you overclock it and it
runs pretty well overall it's got a nice
sort of understated RGB aesthetic which
you can control from the Intel Arc
Control software and an update from the
b580 launch is that Intel has updated
their GPU software like the whole
software stack plan and they've actually
fixed some of the bugs that we
identified on launch day so that's
exciting in terms of IO you have three
display port 2.1 only one of those can
do the ultra high bit rate 13.5 gbit and
I must point out this is not the full
display port 2.1 specification this is
an in between specification shout out to
everybody out there that's trying to
support display port 2.1 in their
products like kvms or whatever because
everybody's like when are you got to get
display port 2.1 KVM it's like when
we've got the full spec this is only a
half measure do you want me to come out
with a KVM that can only do uhb 13.5 and
then later somebody's like I can't do
the 20 gbit standard the other ports use
ultra high bit band
uh10 which technically the astute among
you will say wait a minute it's not just
display port 1.4 the difference is
display stream compression and some
other minor protocol updates so
technically it is display port 2.1 but
yeah only one of these can do the 13.5
bit rate signaling which is standard
like that's that's actually really good
like the other Arc B series battle mage
series gpus do that and then you get one
HDMI 2.1a this was a little bit more
rough of an experience under Linux than
the
b580 uh probably just down to debugging
and maybe something stupid that I'm
doing because there's a lot of a lot of
churn with Mesa and a lot of the other
dependencies so you'll have to wait for
the uh the Linux review for a couple of
days but yeah uh let's take a look at
the performance now if we start with
artificial benchmarks things like 3D
Mark or overall score yeah it's uh it's
pretty shocking this is on our higher
end system a 9800 X 3D system with 32
gigs of ddr5 8000 and yeah the b580 here
is is leading the pack for the gpus that
I tested with 33,37
but it is almost exactly tied with the
Radeon RX 7600 8 gigs I feel I need to
segue for just a moment here because the
artificial benchmarks are often a little
misleading because you look at the
artificial benchmarks and think oh this
will translate into Real World game
performance that is seldom the case
anymore fire strike and time spy are
increasingly divorced from reality I
think it gives us a little bit of a
ballpark in terms of like how things
will perform but it's not really like a
great indicator and our day one review
there are already people that have added
comments in this video talking about how
well you test it with a 9800 x3d you
need to test with a weaker CPU our day
one review said two very important
things there is a somewhat minor fly in
the ointment modern games on an older
CPU with a Cutting Edge GPU where
they're really pulling out all the stops
on the software side the b580 um can be
not a fabulous experience I didn't
recommend the b580 for any system worse
that has a worse CPU than an i7
10700 and that could be you know
depending on if you got a higher end or
a lower end newer CPU you could have a
lower end newer CPU than a 10700 that is
worse than a 10700 a lot of games do
actually use a lot of threads these days
but even for games that don't use a lot
of threads the GPU driver can also use a
lot of threads and Intel has very
cleverly and brilliantly I think
leveraged CPU Hardware to make up for
some deficiencies in their GPU which I
think is a better long-term strategy as
desktop CPUs get more and more and more
powerful it's not as good for for older
upgraders the other thing that I pointed
out in the review is a bit of an anomaly
between 1080P and 1440p performance now
the thing that I want you to notice here
is wait a minute 1080p 1440p this C
doesn't scale resolutions the way that
other cards do if I've got a 4090 and
I'm running at 500 FPS in Shadow of the
Tomb Raider at 1080p oh it's going to
perform really well in 4k this card
performs about the same I mean Real
World gameplay experience not FPS
numbers at 1440p as it does at 1080p so
Intel when they say oh this is a good
card for 1440p what they mean is that
the numbers don't look as good at 1080p
but the 1440p numbers are amazing and
that's probably owing to the GPU
architecture and the engineering choices
that were made here if you just test
1080p historically you could sort of
guesstimate where 1440p performance
would be but on these cards and this
holds true for the b570 as well 1440p
does significantly better than 1080p in
terms of like the maximum number of
pixels that it can push usually the GPU
performance it can push a certain number
of pixels in a certain certain
configuration and when you increase the
resolution the number of pixels it's
pushing doesn't really change all that
much but you get a lower frame rate
because there's more pixels per frame if
that makes sense and I pointed out hey
this this GPU the B 580 is sort of one
of the first gpus is not really like
that even at the $250 price point 1080p
performance was kind of meh but the
1440p performance and rate tracing taken
together that's what really made a good
value and I pointed that out in my day
one review those things still hold true
with the b570 if you have an older CPU
you may not get the full performance out
of the platform but I also tested this
on minium uh motherboards as well as
that 10700 system and I found the
performance reasonable in those
configurations as we get into more games
that would better utilize more threads
or more CPU limited scenarios where the
game itself is using more CPUs you do
get into a situation where the game
competes with the driver for the GPU and
that is never a good thing because that
can make the game experience
significantly worse fortunately this is
something that Intel's aware of and they
can tune and this is a little different
than other gpus in fact the RX 7600 that
I use for this testing can pull ahead of
the 570 and the 5 8 significantly when
you are in those specific CPU constraint
scenarios but that is a bit of an edge
case and if you aren't trying to upgrade
an older system generally I don't think
you're going to run into that unless you
are playing one of the CPU constrained
games that fights with the driver but I
think that that'll sort of be tuned and
figured out as time goes on it's still
pretty good value at like $200 is but
we'll talk about value and stuff in a
second now in terms of game
performance 1080p Gam
yeah okay the the the b580 is leading
here versus the 7600 and the 360 Elite
12 gig but this isn't a bad result and
an old title like shadow of the Tomb
Raider it would be unlikely at highest
you'd be CPU limited especially on an
older
platform and we can see here that the
b580 is pulling just ahead of the
gigabyte orus RTX 360 Elite now for
DirectX 11 and Vulcan in balers Gate 3
it's pretty much the same
across the board the same performance I
mean okay 64 to 71 80 to 84 a little bit
that's a little bit more true with
DirectX 11 a little bit less true with
Vulcan but hey not bad FSR quality on
Warhammer yeah this is a perfectly
playable 60fps for all four of these
cards and this is an important thing to
point out too because between FSR
quality and no upscaling I think this
makes the difference between playable
and less playable like 49 FPS even with
free sync is not not an amazing
experience in Warhammer cyber Punk we
all love to test cyberpunk cyber Punk is
still setting player records like it it
had a rough start but it's a it's a
pretty fun game FSR quality with frame
gen on 169 versus 167 FPS basically
you're saving 30% off the cost of a was
7600 almost not
quite well at least launch pricing that
was a year ago pricing but there's new
gpus coming so that's got to be exciting
right XS quality with frame gen off 8
FPS and no upscaling with frame J off 84
FPS now with rate tracing Ultra at 1080p
93 FPS with FSR quality and frame gen on
H 1080p frame gen like the quality is
like you got to play
it the quality is not amazing but it's
pretty good xcss quality is a little bit
better um for high visual Fidelity but I
was surprised that the performance
difference was as much as it is here 42
to 72 FPS and I'm not sure that this is
a driver bug or some problem with the
graphic selector for the b570 there were
a couple little hitches like this that I
encountered where it seemed like the
b570 was performing better than 42 FPS
and it was repeatable but then I would
come back and retest it later after
playing for a while and it would be
stuck here and I was like well maybe
that's thermals or maybe that's
something no The Thermals are really
really shockingly good The Thermals on
this card uh you know in the stock
config configuration it's like
68° C Max uh with an overclock you can
push it but you know yeah so the other
thing is that uh azck has actually left
you a fair bit of over uh overclocking
headro now this is the outof thebox
performance and so this is basically
performing in line with with Intel and
if you look at the the Boost clocks and
the publish specifications for this 10
gigs of vram versus 12 gigs you're never
going to make that up for an overclock
but for this particular b570 with an
overclock I could claw back the
performance mostly of a b580 so I could
get very very similar performance to a
b580 from a b570 as long as I wasn't
vram constrained and as long as I was
willing to spend 30 minutes to an hour
fiddling with the overclock and power
settings this is a surprisingly more
overclockable GPU than my b580 was for
making significant meaningful uh
performance uplift but
occasionally games like cyberpunk a
little weird and these graphs I tried to
display I tried to put all this together
with no overclocking Pure outof thebox
Performance so that you would know what
to expect and this xss result is a
little strange the no upscaling result
gave me sort of confidence that hey this
is probably just a a b570 thing because
22 versus 40 FPS with the no upscaling
and frame gen off is sort of more in
line with what I would expect for for
this and then like 93 between 93 and 119
FPS that's a pretty big difference now
for 1440 this is G CPU offers a
reasonable 1440p experience mostly I
worry about the future with the 10 gigs
of vram like 12 gigs of vram for future
AAA titles I mean that may be pushing it
but for 10 gigs of vram wasn't really
bumping up against vram limits mostly
but again everything else on this card
the difference between 94 and 109
FPS uh I'm surprised that there was that
much of a difference I sort of expected
everything to look a little bit more
like balder's gate and we can see here
that there's really no penalty for
playing Boulders gate at 1440p versus
1080p unless you just physically have a
1080p monitor in which case it might be
time to upgrade now cyberpunk at 1440p
this is the playable sweet spot this is
awesome the performance here again
calling back to the 1080p performance
look at the 1440p performance why would
you just not play in 1440p FSR quality
frame gen on 1440p those quality
concerns that I was talking about at
1080p basically go away you're off to a
better experience here frame gen this is
a perfectly reasonable experience and
once you've played this you're you're
not going to want to like you're not
going to want to play with FSR quality
and frame gen off and and xess quality
with frame gen off was was better than
XS visually but it has more CPU overhead
so again remember if you play this with
a worse game XS is going to cost you a
lot more than FSR does FSR is very low
CPU overhead so that is very good for
people that are playing on older CPUs in
general and that is true more more true
on the Intel card than even some of
amd's own cards but you know it is what
it is the F1 2024 results l line up
basically where you to expect based on
the other reviews going into this I was
expecting the b570 to basically perform
identically to the b580 or close to it
uh just except in situations where you
were vram limited but with F1 2024 we're
not really vram limited especially when
we're we're talking about 1440p and and
everything that's going on here um with
the 1440p setup in the game I am
surprised that it is 20 FPS slower with
XDS quality and frame gen on even on a
9800x 3D um but again you can claw this
back with overclocking so with
overclocking the GPU I could get up
around 134 FPS and still have a
reasonable experience but again out of
the box performance it's clear that
Intel is going super conservative with
the clocks because you don't see it in
the temperature of the card you don't
see it in anything else it's may be good
for a small form factor build if if
about 100 FPS is reasonable for you and
and a lot of titles then you can have a
cool and quiet small form factor build
10 gigs of amp vram gets it done etc etc
I mean may maybe the choice would make
sense blender 4.0 you know percentage
wise yeah it falls off here it's like
I'm I'm seeing a trend it's like oh it's
it's it's a card that's like 133%
cheaper but also 133% slower interesting
and finally our geek bench six results
just for good measure between open uh
between open CL and Vulcan the pit
Creator Suite is also not bad especially
when we're doing a comparison to the uh
RX 7600 8 gig so overall what's the
verdict well it's cheaper but it's also
slower but you can overclock it but no
amount of overclocking is going to make
up for 2 gigs less
vram it's an interesting card I feel
like what Intel has done here is
basically uh
every piece of Arc battle mage silicon
that for whatever reason would not work
in a b580 they've put in a b570 and so
they've set the floor absurdly low for
the b57
but that's good because that gives you a
lot of overclocking
Headroom okay fine that makes sense
ASRock has given you an Overkill cooler
even though it's a two slot cooler two
slot two fan cooler so that you can do
significant overclocking so I don't know
it'll be interesting to see the comments
once people get these and they do the
overclock what the overclocking Lottery
looks like but for me personally I hit
the overclocking Lottery jackpot with
the b570 so I don't know what to make of
that I mean this is the OC Edition
asrock's probably doing their own
binning there's probably a non OC
Edition
right but OC it does if it were me I'd
probably spend the extra money to get
the b580 though even with all of that
even if I knew that I had a 90% chance
I'm not saying it's a 90% chance it
might be a 50% chance it might be a 10%
chance but even if there was a 90%
chance that you could overclock it and
clawback and get most of the performance
of a b580 out of a b570 but still have 2
gigs less vram the cost differential
between these two if you can get a b580
at MSRP i' probably just go for for the
B the MSRP b580 because it's a fair bit
more guaranteed performance and the b580
also has a little bit of overclocking
Headroom depending on which model you
get and the cooling everything else
because again the out of the box
reference like the reference cooler on
this thing keeps it cooler than 75c in
basically every scenario and if the
reference cooler can do that then you
can imagine what the partners have done
so interesting it's an interesting
launch the b580 has been hard hard to
get so I think that's probably good that
Intel is selling more than they expected
to or they're trying to get supplies and
everything else but we've also got new
gpus launching from both Nvidia and AMD
which could change the
calculus don't know yet and what this
level one I'm signing out find me in the
level one forums